welcome to the League of Legends
champion spotlight featuring Brock the
heart of the Freljord
if at first you do not succeed please
tell me what did his life rob is a hero
of the Freljord a champion strongman
famed for his selfless and legendary
feats once a simple goat herder Brom
found an unbreakable door and uses it as
a shield to protect man and creature
alike on his journey through runeterra
in game Brom is a tanky support with the
ability to defend allies from a barrage
of attacks before hammering out his own
immense crowd control abilities father
always big things come in small packages
whenever Brom attacks an enemy he
applies a stack of his passive
concussive blows if Brom dishes out four
blows to the head he deals in bursts of
magic damage and stuns his enemy for a
brief period after Brahms basic attacks
against them feel extra magic damage
although they won't receive additional
stacks of concussive blows there are two
things worth noting here first brahms
allies can help trigger the stun with
basic attacks and on hit abilities
second Bronk initiate concussive blows
against multiple enemies simultaneously
Brahms Q is winters bite Brom punches
his shield sending out a frozen skill
shot that damages and heavily slows the
first enemy struck winters bite also
applies concussive blows
giving him the opportunity to stun
distant enemies
winters bite is essential for gaining
Lane dominance tag your opponents with
it from range to give your marksman
opportunities for great trades Brahms W
is stand behind me targeted ability that
Brom can only use on himself and his
friends stand behind me since Brahma
leaping to an allied champion or minion
giving him and his ally bonus armor and
magic resistance
note that Brom will automatically stand
between his target and the nearest enemy
champion allowing him to fabulously
block skill shots with his awesome body
seriously check out those pecs you stand
behind me whenever you're separated from
your allies since it allows you to cross
over terrain you can keep yourself in a
good position while buffing their
defenses unbreakable Brahms II is his
signature defensive ability on
activation from raises his shield in a
target direction for a few seconds
blocking all damage from the first
incoming attack or spell any subsequent
damage from that direction is reduced by
a percentage while the shield remains
active the most notable thing about
unbreakable is that brahms shield
intercepts and stops all incoming
projectiles even those targeted allies
behind him
this allows broth to tank damage and
crowd control effects for his team
here's one nuance worth pointing out
though unbreakable doesn't intercept non
projectile abilities he does reduce the
damage he takes provided his shield is
facing the source of the damage
for example if unbreakable faces the
center of zyra's ultimate fraud will
take reduced damage but he won't prevent
damage to his allies braum can cast
other abilities and moves slightly
faster while the shield is raised and
keeps his shield pointed at the initial
target direction regardless of his
movement finally as awesome as
unbreakable is it's not awesome enough
to block turret attacks or true damage
unbreakable can negate major area of
effect spells for your teammates save if
our hard-hitting Ultimates to block off
a barrage of attacks brahms ultimate is
glacial fissure braum slams his shield
into the ground sending out a huge shock
wave that knocks up damages and slows
enemies in alive enemy units immediately
around Brahm are knocked up
significantly higher than enemies
further away if there are no enemy
champions immediately around Brahm the
first champion in the shock wave is
knocked up higher instead glacial
fissure also leaves behind a large zone
of ice that slows all enemies glacial
fissure is great for disengaging from
teamfights the ability creates a slow
zone that will handicap your opponent's
especially in the narrow corridors of
the jungle
braum strikes his own destiny one of his
many ability stand behind me is an
extremely versatile skill that has
several offensive and defensive options
when paired with the rest of his kit
let's look at a few important plays
you'll need in order to become master of
the mustache
the first is blocking for an ally
determine what direction the most damage
or crowd control is coming from then
leap in to get between danger and your
ally before using unbreakable to disrupt
the attack
this is your basic defensive pattern for
clutch saves and requires good timing
when assisting allies in a chase or
aggressive play you stand behind me
instead as a gap closer by choosing an
ally closest to your enemy you can often
put yourself in range to slow them with
winters bite since the - automatically
places you on the side closest to your
enemy you have an easier time lining up
the skill shot
you can also jump to allied minions
allowing for some tricky plays in Lane
finally if one of your friends gets
caught out in a bad situation surrounded
by enemy champions rom can come to the
rescue
you stand behind me to jump to the
center of the action then knock up and
slow everyone around your ally with your
oldsman this will give your team a
chance to disengage or allow other
allies to step in and help if needed
in Lane a successful Grom will
constantly look for opportunities to
stack his passive for a stun by tagging
Jonna with winters bite he makes it easy
for Quinn to follow up and pick her off
with the bonus damage and stun turning
his attention to Vayne he stacks
concussive blows with another Q and
basic attacks helping focus her down
before she can land the killing blow on
Quinn Brom is especially adept at
helping allies survive ganks with his W
and E as soon as Quinn is caught out he
immediately used to stand behind me to
boost her defenses and help her survive
focus fire from Pantheon and Vayne
note that Brom makes sure to stay behind
Quinn while using unbreakable so he can
tank any attacks directed at her forcing
Vayne to hit him instead as they retreat
brahms unbreakable completely negates
damage from the first attack or spell
that hits him so with careful timing you
can effectively cancel your opponent's
most damaging attack here Brom blocks
the gold card and the damage reduction
gives him just enough defense to survive
braum excels when sticking close to his
allies as soon as twitch appears Brom
repositions to the front of his Marchman
ready to not only intercept witches
damage but also hit both enemies with
glacial fissure rather than chase four
kills Brom sticks with Eze reel and
applies concussive blows to any of his
targets when playing Brom your goal
isn't so much to dive on the enemy as it
is to keep your squishy friends un'
squashed stand behind me slow cooldown
allows Brom multiple chances to
reposition and help allies in log
teamfights
in this example rom quickly finds
himself singled out after committing to
the fend Garen he uses stand behind me
to jump to misfortune and although he
dies he helps MF pick up the triple kill
a well-played braum boldly throws
himself in harm's way to protect his
friends when timed correctly unbreakable
has a potential to shield allies against
tons of damage with great positioning
here Brom turns a lethal AoE combo into
more of a mild annoyance almost
single-handedly turning the tide of this
fight
groms big heart needs a lot of
protection focus on health armor and
magic resistance tenacity is also
especially helpful since unbreakable
means Brom will be tanking crowd control
meant for his allies mixin cooldown
reduction to maximize Brom zone crowd
controlled and you'll have a heavy
frontline specialist ready to defend
against any amount of aggression or
unexpected bear wrestling thanks for
tuning into the Brom champion spotlight
please subscribe to the Riot Games
YouTube channel and leave us your
comments just below the video
train hard little border one day you'll
be strong like baby